first of all I think you must
make good records
I believe that's the secret to
everyone's success
and then next I would have to say work
good performances when people come to
see you live
I believe those two attributes to my
success I think I always wished that
people could sing along with me you know
I'd love when you go to a concert and
they sing all your songs I've gotten
that this time so it's been another type
of recognition for me and and
achievement I am how I've always been I
I care about myself I take care of
myself I I've never been a drug addict
or an alcoholic a little champagne a
little red wine here and there but I've
never smoked so let's just say if we can
attribute that to to my health and I'm
an energetic person I want time for
myself now to enjoy life
and I'm taking that time I've been
before the audience and we've both had a
good time for a very long time and now I
won't be on such a stage anymore I'll be
in and out I might run across Jagger
stage every now and then or or Ron Adams
I'll do things but not
at this what do you call this all of
this smaller smaller scale
well joining me now is Liz Mitchell the
original lead singer of Boney M and she
knew and worked with Tina Turner it is
lovely to talk to you today you first
met her in the 1970s just looking at
those videos I mean what was she like
she appeared to have a Magnetic
Personality
she was very kind lady very gentle I was
very happy that she was not uh Too Proud
to talk to me or thought that I wasn't
worthy to to to share her her time with
um I've I've always always said and we
could have been very good friends if it
were not that artists travel around the
world and we kind of lose contact with
each other but I did have her very close
to my heart it's a beautiful human being
she was a magnificent singer and you
know first class performer how much of
her success we heard there from from
those interviews with her one was good
records but also was was working hard
performing hard how much was do you
think was down to sheer hard work and
staying power
I think that her staying power was based
on everything she said the fact that she
does deliver completely when she
performs at the energy level is so high
and um also she was fortunate to have
had fantastic records lyrics that meant
something to her she was able to deliver
them and I think that
um when you hear her songs you hear a
truth she is she's not telling you a
non-truth she's definitely speaking
clearly in her songs and
life away from the stage
then included a really horrific period
where she was a victim of domestic
violence the fact that she spoke out
about that it changed a lot for a lot of
women a lot of women looked at what
she'd gone through and and Drew courage
from her story did she did she talk
about that much did you think that that
she realized the impact that it had on
people
I don't think um that she um would talk
about that ordinarily with just anyone
or everyone she was
um more encouraging in where the artist
was concerned you know to give you good
props and to make you feel good about
yourself the story broke and many those
people who knew about it uh knew about
it
um and and those maybe most of those
people are the ones who talked about it
um and but
I would say that she did she handled her
life really well and she overcame her
struggles really well and today her
whole image is a testimony for many
women